du nouveau sur france télévisions en ce
début d'année si vous avez l'oeil vous
vous l'aurez remarqué depuis le début de
ce journal nous nous sommes dotés comme
on dit d'une nouvelle identité visuelle
mais ce n'est pas tout la cinquième qui
a intégré la holding france télévisions
s'appellera désormais france 5
lors de la lex romuald derrière les
écrans en mouvement le nouveau logo de
france 3 moderniser dynamiser il est le
cinquième que connaît la chaîne depuis
sa création
on se souvient de l'oeil a paru en 1975
mais aussi des lettres d'or de france
région 3 mais aujourd'hui c'est aussi
tout un groupe france télévisions qui
change d'identité visuelle nouveau logo
pour france 2 pour la cinquième qui
devient france 5 et surtout pour france
télévisions qui se conjugue désormais au
pluriel compter les on prend un s alors
qu'ils n'avaient pas ça exprime
clairement l'idée de variétés de
diversité et l'ouverture aux futurs
projets notamment de des chaînes
numériques terrestres
ça c'est le laisse deuxième élément
c'est qu'au lieu d'être un cumul des
logos des chaînes il ya la création d'un
logo autonome et que c'est plutôt ce
logo qui inspire les logos des chaînes
depuis deux ans le groupe france
télévisions on traverse une période de
profonds changements
en août 2000 la loi sur l'audiovisuel
instaurer une société holding pour
accueillir les trois chaînes publiques
le système graphique se devait de suivre
cette évolution nous affirmons comme un
groupe uni avec france 2 france 3 et la
cinquième devenu francs 5 mai un groupe
uni veut pas dire qu'il fait la même
chose que les trois chaînes vont garder
leur identité aux yeux pour les
téléspectateurs simplement les valeurs
qui
qui les portes sont les mêmes pour
souligner cette ambition la marque
france télévisions apparaîtra désormais
à l'antenne et les nouveaux logos de
chaque chaîne seront présents sur la
majeure partie des programmes